oh hi TV lovers I'm your captain Liana
galera and this is ship worthy the only
show devoted to celebrating the most
swim worthy couples on TV and today
you'd better brace yourselves because
we're voyaging into the quaint yet crazy
town of Riverdale and this episode is
all about the relationship between
sherab Lawson and tawny topaz aka Joni
feel free to travel in addition to
highlighting the couples best scenes in
naughty or nice I'll be bringing you an
exclusive never-before-seen interview
with Vanessa Morgan talking all about
why she loves working with real-life BFF
Madeleine Pech as her fictional
girlfriend I think they both bring out
the best versions of each other now if
you guys don't already know I have
another series on et's YouTube channel
called Sweetwater secrets where each
week I fangirl with you over every new
episode of Riverdale so I've been
interviewing Natalie and Vanessa since
the very beginning of season two and I'm
proud to say that I've been personally
shipping Cheryl and Toni together since
before the two ladies even shared a
scene I actually said I'm kind of
already shipping you guys and I don't
even know if it's gonna happen I have no
idea I have no idea where all of this
came from and then once this
relationship began to blossom
I checked with both our girls about the
proper pronunciation of this beloved
[ __ ] I think I just clarified that it's
Shoni I'm not Tony
it is not Joni I've been saying showing
me Cheryl
Joanie its Joanie now that's the name I
can get the end
so basically Nana rose and I were kind
of the og Shoni shippers but just how
did show me for sale on to our screams
it's time to take a look back at how it
all began in anchors
we first met a sarcastically spunky
tawny topaz when Jughead was transferred
over to South Side High and thanks to a
brief fling that we're not going to talk
about we discovered the truth behind
Tony's romantic preferences and went
across anyways now Cheryl and Tony's
first interaction came at the Serpent's
first police drag race in episode 206
and although the scene was short it
ignited a fiery beginning for these two
I usually do the honor
not today ChaCha I was born for this
moment their crosstown tension continued
when the Serpent's were forced to
slither into the Northside and our two
passionate ladies proved to be worthy
adversaries why don't you come over here
and say that to my face
family queen of the bus cars due to a
ruthless mother and unsavory home lies
and feelings of being left from the
group Cheryl continued to brutally lash
out but Tony was the only one brave
enough to break through Cheryl's fiery
walls are you okay no I'm really not
oh I was gonna go grab a seat alone
unless you want some company no pressure
and then thanks to Tony support we
finally learned the truth of Cheryl's
romantic past I loved someone
her name was Heather she said I was
deviant with Tony by Cheryl's side the
two developed a seriously sweet
friendship that slowly but surely
evolved into one of the best
relationships to root for you're
sensational
but when Cheryl's heinous mother sent
away to gay conversion therapy
Shoni became officially official with
this heart-stopping rescue mission kiss
[Music]
alright guys I've said it before and I
will say it again
who needs a knight in shining armor when
you can have a princess in a sultry cat
suit now that we've seen how this couple
first came afloat let's dive into their
best sweet and sultry scenes first up in
the nice list is the moment when Tony
confronted Cheryl in the bathroom over
her attempt at core for relationships
sabotage never better idea
why don't you tell me what's bothering
you because clearly a lot of pain okay
you're sapphic serpent hands my body
true this is not one of Cheryl's nicest
moments with Tony but I love this scene
because it was really the beginning of
it all and I think that Tony yeah - next
up it was so sweet when Tony stood by
her girl at the blossom will reading and
why on earth would you be there I
invited her to be my emotional support
and it was even sweeter when they showed
their first PDC public displays of show
knee in front of Cheryl's homophobic
month
watching Tony support and comfort Cheryl
in the musical episode hit all the right
notes and when Cheryl rescued Tony from
penny Peabody it was a perfect bullseye
untie her you serpent hag but that
moment needed more than just a side hug
sorry to say and of course after seeing
how well Cheryl slithered in with the
Serpent's it was amazing to see how Tony
welcomed her red hot girl to the
Southside as for those naughty scenes
well their first kiss will always give
me all the feels but we definitely need
to look back at the time those two
vixens shared a bed together
he didn't on two of my coma girls
tonight but I knew my hideous mother
would never allow me to write just you
witches
I crave now the chemistry between them
was electric and somehow that year kiss
was almost sexier than if they had
actually locked lips and I don't know
about you but I've been craving a lot
more sultry scenes from this couple heck
I've been craving any scenes between
them unfortunately a few key Shoni
scenes were cut from season two and I'm
the only one who got the truth straight
from the stars about what was really
supposed to happen between them in the
finale take a look at what they told me
I think as far as its planned her and
Tony will be living with me in a row so
but we didn't end up seeing that in the
finale
well the moment that was cut from the
episode was you know me just showing up
to her house like me pulling up in my
motorcycle chorus and I went up to the
door and I have my bag and I just like
smile at her and she's like welcome but
you know we didn't up keeping it I think
that's a great idea I think that you
know that gives us season three to
further explore relationship and some
getting super serious moving in together
you know that could maybe lead to bad
things we're such a new couple I wish
you could have read the original script
it was which original script for the end
episode okay there's some fun stuff in
there interesting yeah and I really
think we're saving all the Shoni for
season 3 I really do that's what I've
been told anyways by the way I can
describe it season 3 C thing see what
happened I'm like yeah I know we're all
so bummed that so many show me scenes
were cut from season 2 but I've got
something that I think will make you
smile I recently caught up with Vanessa
Morgan at the CW up front and here's
what she had to say about this
one-of-a-kind riverdale relationship you
know we've started a new show and it's
called ship worthy and we'll be doing an
episode all about Cheryl and Tony
how they got together and why we love
them why do you think that Cheryl and
Tony are ship worthy I think we're ship
worthy because we are Ryder dies and we
look good together we need yes we need
to get that motorcycle scene in season
three yeah and she's gonna be on the
back of my motorcycle and I think
everybody's gonna want to say that why
do you feel like fans love this couple
so much yeah I think they're really real
I think they both bring out the best
versions of each other they're both
lucky strong confident girls and able to
let their walls down with each other and
allow me to be vulnerable and I think
they're something so beautiful in that
and of course getting to be an on-screen
relationship with your off-screen BFF
it's got to be so much fun
I mean you couldn't ask for a better
person to play your girlfriend like the
chances in this world of your best
friend in real life playing your
on-screen girlfriend is pretty crazy so
I'm really lucky overall I love Shoney's
relationship because they've been 100%
honest with each other every single step
of the way you know Tony was the only
one who could see that Cheryl used
verbal venom to hide her pain and Cheryl
in turn found her internal strength and
a new family with Tony these two may not
have been given as much riverdale screen
time as they deserve but as always
Shoney's relationship is worth the wait
well maybe we should make it official
there you have it this concludes our
first Shoni episode of ship worthy about
don't you worry as I continue to
interview Madeline patch and Vanessa
Morgan I'll be back with follow-up
episodes about Shoni and where their
relationship will be sailing to next but
for now please give this video a like
and then drop anchor in the comments
below to tell me why you love Shoni as a
couple oh and which naughty or nice
seems made you blush I wanna know plus
if you strongly ship any other TV
couples tell me comment or tweet me with
your nominations of who you think I
should feature in future episodes of
ship worthy and until next time
bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]